and the pentagon has opened a new office
to investigate ufos called all domain
anomaly resolution office
what do you think about this office do
you think it can help
alleviate the in the way which this
hearing perhaps has failed
to improve more the scientific rigor
and the seriousness of investigating
ufos
i think that remains to be seen i think
it's a step in the right direction but
it's a step that was taken because the
previous step didn't happen
right so um the aoi msg was the
progeny essentially of the aaro or arrow
and you know the name was changed
because
nothing was happening and it was
essentially just a confusing mess of
words that were created to make this
topic unpalatable
um the airborne object identification
synchronization management group
quite the mouthful
i practiced that uh but the new all
domain anomaly resolution office you
know from my perspective at least at
least the perspective that they're
putting out they they seem to want to be
open they put out a twitter handle
they're out they're going out on twitter
and communicating saying they want to
keep this open
but you know that's going to run into a
classification wall
well so uh dr sean
kirkpatrick seems like an interesting
guy
he does yes
so he he's got a
um evan looked into deeply but he seems
to have sort of
he's coming from like a science research
perspective like uh uh background
so he he might be
at least in the right
um mindset the right background to kind
of lead the serious investigation i
think so i'll just say generally um you
know the office has been receptive to
aila reaching out in order to
collaborate which has been a positive
sign um also pass the same kudos to
dr spurgle and nasa's uh
effort as well
i i see these organizations that are
standing up i do see them as
as good faith efforts that are coming
about through a lot of difficulty and
negotiation most likely right and i see
these as as a small
door opening that if we can take
advantage of can lead to
a much more productive relationship
between these organizations how do you
put pressure on this kind of thing does
it come from the civilian leadership
does it come from sort of congress and
presidents does it come from the public
does the public have any power to put
pressure on this
or
is the the giant wall of bureaucracy
going to protect it against any public
pressure what do you think i think we've
been in in that latter state for a while
but
you know society seems to be a bit
different nowadays you know we have the
ability to communicate and to group and
to to form relationships in a way that
haven't been able to
be present in the past we've been able
to
do research for better or worse on our
own you know in a way that hasn't been
able to happen before
and so
i sense that people are a bit less
willing to kind of buy the bottom line
statement from
those in power as they used to be back
when they didn't have access to those
tools
and so i do think there is a massive
role for the general society general
populist to play to show that they are
interested in this
because it's not that i don't think the
politicians or the leaders in the in the
pentagon it's not that they don't like
this topic necessarily or think it's
toxic per se but they exist in a culture
where this has been toxic and they don't
feel comfortable talking about it and
these are people that have spent their
entire careers you know working towards
a goal and getting to very high
positions within government and so this
is very against their nature to take a
stance on a topic like this
and so the fact that these are standing
up
even if they do have a small budget or
if they struggled a bit at first i still
think it's a massive change you know and
it's a big step away from that stigma
that has been pervading this topic for
so long and you're actually part of
alleviating the stigma for
some somebody that's as credible as
intelligent as like varied in background
able to speak about these things that's
a big risk that you took
but it's extremely valuable because it's
alleviating the stigma i thank you for
saying that but it didn't feel like much
of a risk for me you know i didn't come
out about aliens right or whatever i
i had a safety problem that i started
asking questions about and you know i
went down a road as a navy trained
aviation safety officer right that sent
me to school for six weeks in pensacola
to be a safety officer you know
we're almost hitting these objects and
it's not something that happened in the
past and we want to understand it it's
happening right now like these these
occurrences are still happening aviators
are flying right now are still flying by
these things and in fact
i mentioned i was a instructor pilot
i
had a student call me about eight months
ago or so
and he's like hey sir you know i made it
to the fleet finally uh you know i had
trained him how to fly and then he goes
to f-18 he goes another year of training
and then he gets out to his squadron on
the east coast and he's flying with the
senior member of uh the base nes oceana
where the fighters fly out of
um senior row five row six and it was
kind of a bad weather day and so they
said hey you know if the weather's not
good enough for us to do this
dogfighting set we'll we'll go out and
do a uap hunt you know and see if we
can't find any things or take a look at
them you know i don't know if it was
ingest or not but you know this they i
actually would say it's not just because
there were there were notices that were
being briefed about this being a safety
hazard at this point and so
i now that i i think about it it likely
wasn't just long story short they went
flying the weather was too bad they did
go into ufo and they physically saw one
you know and he called me up and said
hey sir i saw a cuban sphere they're
still out here you know years later and
so it's almost like a generational issue
you know for these fighter pilots at
least on east coast but that's great
that they can talk about it right
exactly exactly they feel at least
comfortable they have a reporting
mechanism and so that was one of the
problems that i noticed that we have a
lot of reporting mechanisms to take care
of safety issues and and even tactical
issues when the time is right in order
to keep track of what's going on but
there's no way to communicate about this
sure we could submit a hazard report but
nothing's actually being investigated
and if this is a tactical
vulnerability or something more it
deserves attention
you